欢迎来到崇洋Talk 财富是认知的变现。
这是一党传递财富与投资多元认知的栏目。
我是主理人苏太封。
雄势让人欲闷 牛势却可能让人更为骄躁。
为什么会产生这个现象呢？
今天我想从心理学的角度跟大家讲一讲这个话题。
答案要说简单 也很简单。
那就是牛势中 总有人比你赚得更多。
尤其是结构性牛势当中。
采种封口的投资人天天享受上涨的愉悦。
春风得意马蹄挤
不再封口的不仅分享不到愉悦的氛围。
还可能因为热门赛道的资金抽血效应。
而遭受禁止婴爹的苦恼。
今年2月底
每一战争到6月底以来的行情。
就是这种极致分化的典型代表。
除了光以外 其余板块都暗然失色。
站在光里的 与不站在光里的投资人业绩表现。
冰火两重天
股市时人性的放大气。
在一场结构性牛势当中。
这种放大效应更是淋漓尽致。
如果说雄势更多的是考验投资者。
单一为渡的耐心
这种极致的结构性牛势。
在不仅考验耐心
还考验你的贪婪 嫉妒等本能欲望。
如果看不透管不好这份欲望。
不仅容易陷入无尽的焦躁。
甚至还可能让你的投资动作变形。
最终落得两头不讨好的尴尬局面。
7月份以来科技股剧烈调整。
老登股反弹
此前一些没熬住而去追光的老登投资人。
已经遭受了两面挨打的痛苦。
话说回来 看破欲望弹劾容易。
毕竟他们是内置于人类基因深处的原生设施。
连王阳明先生都说。
破山中贼异 破心中贼难。
碰巧最近读到乐类激拉尔的。
欲望几何理论
觉得对破心中贼很有启发。
所以用这期播客来跟大家做个分享和隐身探导。
乐类激拉尔是谁呢？
是法国当代极具开创性的哲学家。
文学批评家 人类学家。
被欲望的先知 人文领域的大文。
激拉尔主张跳出单一学科的束缚。
他以沙士比亚 普鲁斯特 斯汤达等。
文学大师的作品为窃口。
挖掘人类欲望的规律。
在激拉尔之前
学术界对欲望的解读普遍是从。
主体到课题的直线模型。
这就是人因为自身的需求 本能 喜好。
而产生欲望
但激拉尔发现
这种理论完全无法解释。
生活中大量的矛盾现象。
比如 人们常常不知道自己想要什么？
只会疯狂追逐别人追捧的事物。
原本没有价值的东西。
一旦成为他人的欲望目标。
就会瞬间变得急剧性的。
他因此提出了欲望几何学理论。
他的基本要点是
第一 欲望不是直线 而是三角形。
这个三角形结构由三个顶点组成。
主体是产生欲望的人。
课题是被渴望的东西或人。
借体也就是没借
是主体模仿的对象。
我们之所以渴望某个东西。
往往不是因为他本身有多大价值。
而是因为别人也想要。
或者别人拥有他
这个别人就是借体。
而他的欲望就是通过模仿借体而产生的。
第二点 欲望是抄来的。
基拉认为除了最基本的生理需求。
比如饿了要吃饭之外。
人类绝大多数的欲望都不是。
发自内心的原创
而是通过模仿他人得来的。
恋爱中的情侣
觉得必须互相送某种礼物。
吃某个大餐
或者你想买某个名牌包。
这些行为模式往往是因为。
看到了社交媒体上的别人。
或身边的朋友都是这么做而已。
在经典文学作品中。
唐奇克德就是一个典型的模仿者。
他因为沉迷歧视小说。
从而产生了成为游侠歧视的欲望。
这是一种对凯摩的模仿。
弗洛败比下的爱马。
包法利夫人
他的悲剧在于他不断模仿。
浪漫小说中的爱情凯摩。
从而产生了对奢华生活。
和浪漫爱情的无尽欲望。
第三点
存在着两种不同的模仿欲望。
根据我们与界体的距离。
基拉尔将欲望分为两种情况。
第一种是外部界体的情况。
这种情况下
界体和你的距离非常遥远。
比如说历史伟人
神话英雄
大明星等等
由于差距太大
你们不会在现实中。
争夺同一个东西
所以这种模仿
通常是崇拜时的
第二种情况是内部界体的情况。
媒介或者说界体和你处在一个层面。
比如说身边的同事。
同学朋友
由于距离太近
你们渴望的资源是有限的。
比如说生殖机会
同一个恋人等等
这就必然导致
竞争 嫉妒 甚至仇恨。
我们在职场或者生活中。
感到的内卷和无意义的攀比。
往往就是陷入了内部媒介的陷阶。
基拉写道
欲望就像万有引力一样。
不会单独存在于
任何事物或者个体内部。
它诞生于我们能够相互影响的空间当中。
换句话说
我们所有的欲望
本质上都是他人欲望的投影。
美国经济学家查尔斯·金德尔伯格。
在他的经典著作
《疯狂 惊恐和崩溃中》
写过一句十分扎心的话。
他说
最令人烦心 最令人头痛的事。
莫故意看到朋友发大财。
这跟现在的年轻人说。
怕朋友吃苦 更怕朋友开鹿虎。
是一个意思
金德尔伯格说这句话的时候。
基拉尔还没有发明出欲望几何血。
他是从历史上无数次金融泡沫中。
得出的直观感受
从最早的玉金箱泡沫。
到后来的南海泡沫。
运河泡沫 铁路泡沫 互联网泡沫。
泡沫催生着新科技和新生活滚滚向前。
同时也一次次催生着财富造神。
又毁灭的故事
每一轮泡沫 刀火锁往往是新科技和新发明。
它激发了人们对于未来新城大海的想象。
但是让泡沫最终燃起熊熊大火的。
这是人心的利的欲望。
前不久 我在一个大型的行业会议上。
亲耳听到一位投资人说。
赚不到一百倍 就对不起这个时代。
这波爱爱牛适中 确实有一些人赚得盆满泊满。
这种发生在你身边的十倍百倍造富神话。
正是基拉尔所说的欲望没见。
它撩拨起人心中的贪婪和嫉妒。
从而让人们一次次冲进新科技 新赛道的风口。
最终将泡沫推向机制。
从这个机制来说 泡沫的产生和破灭。
是注定无法避免的。
泡沫论的支持者会说。
正是泡沫出进了新科技的发展状大。
推动了社会的发展和进步。
的确啊 如果每个人都极致理性。
确实不会有人为高度不确定性的未来买单。
所以我们不应当简单的将泡沫定义为贬义词。
某种意义上它可能正是进化的代名词。
关于这一点 看看生物界会更为清楚。
赛轮盖地大草原上每次缴码的签席。
当它们浩浩荡荡独卢狂奔想要过河的时候。
总是引发剧烈的踩踏。
一批缴码会成为牺牲品。
而信存者这踏着同类的尸体迁行。
有种叫周期禅的昆虫。
昆虫在腹化后就会直接潜入土中。
靠牺食植物和树木根部的枝叶。
在地下折腐十七年。
欺满之后 数十亿。
也有人说是数万亿成虫。
纷纷于五月的第二周破土而出。
并迅速开始疯狂的交配。
在树上敞完软后
所有成虫都会在六月底之前死亡。
大约六周后 腥肤化粗的幼虫。
将再度从树上返回地下。
继续开启下一个十七年的生命轮回。
周期禅的这种进化策略。
被称为补食者饱和效应。
它在过去的岁月中一直非常成功。
因为没有任何补食者。
能在短短几周内吃掉这么多的食物。
补食者饱和效应就是泡沫效应。
所以在泡沫中前进。
可能正式进化的基本规律。
或者说进化的备论。
这个备论清晰地展现出。
进化是有代价的
问题在于
没有谁希望成为被踩它的脚码。
或者被吃掉的周期禅。
而是都想成为顺利渡河的那一个。
投资行为客观上有利于技术。
经济和社会的进步。
但是我想所有投资者。
也都希望通过投资。
实现财富的长期保质和争取。
而不是成为进化的炮灰。
想做到两者的平衡。
需要高度的技巧与智慧。
好在他已经被投资前辈们所提炼。
并迎接为经典
本杰明格雷厄姆
是1929年史诗级股市泡沫。
及大峰盘的清理者。
大峰盘之后
他过早的在1930年进场超底。
导致管理的基金整体亏损70%。
兵力破产
这次惨动经历
让他意识到杠杆与投机的危害。
痛定思痛于1934年出版政权分析。
在这本书中
他对投资与投机进行了严格区分。
并提炼出股权思维安全编辑。
市场先生三大核心理念。
从此被称为价值投资之父。
巴菲特在这套理念基座上。
加入了能力圈的重要一环。
尽管巴菲特和盲格等投资大事的发言光大。
价值投资成为了投资显靴。
然后尽管有巴盟等人猪狱在前。
巴菲特股东会每年朝圣者露云。
但真正在投资事件中。
见行价值投资的人却少之又少。
这是为什么呢？
价值投资最难的可能不在于技巧。
而在于心性
因为它是一套逆人性的投资哲学。
情绪及不稳定的市场先生。
天天出现在你面前。
十二忧郁 十二狂躁。
忧郁时让你绝望
狂躁时则在你的身边。
营造出各种一夜报复的欲望媒介。
又是你忘记纪律
加入你追我感的游戏。
不知道巴菲特有没有读过基拉尔。
但他应该深知欲望媒介的厉害之处。
1956年
26岁的巴菲特
在老师哥雷厄姆的公司工作3年之后。
选择回到了偏僻的老家奥马哈小镇。
原相比那里的欲望媒介密度。
显然要小很多
无独有偶
1968年
55岁的约翰邓普顿爵士。
也选择从华尔街搬到了。
搬到了巴哈马的拿骚定居。
在那里
华尔街日报要晚一个星期才能到达。
无论巴忙还是邓普顿。
他们都像是大营引于股市的市外高人。
善于屏蔽外界的干扰。
芒哥说
从某种意义上说
我们更像是学者而不是生意人。
我总是会坐下来静静的思考几个小时。
我并不在意在很长的时间里。
没有任何事情发生。
当然这份定力于近期。
也与他们早早的参透了。
财富积累的秘方有关。
芒哥说过早在60年代的时候。
我和巴菲特参照福利表。
就已经计算出
我们将来会非常非常有钱。
只要我们一步一步文扎文打。
不犯重大错误
不做傻事
慢慢来
我们将来就会变得非常有钱。
我们从来没有怀疑过。
说这话的时候
芒哥大概40岁左右。
巴菲特这是30多岁。
年轻的他们已经参透了福利之道。
巴菲特60多年投资生涯。
平均年化收益19.7%。
没有任何一个单年收益率。
超过60%
所以福利之道不是一业报复之道。
而是慢复之道
然而慢就是快
慢复之道加上时间的杠杆。
却是财富的真正康庄之道。
不是人人都可以成为巴菲特。
但是福利的原理
对于每个人来说
却是越早掌握越好。
假设一个20岁的年轻人。
他拥有33万本金。
通过投资获取每年10%的收益。
那么到他60岁快退休的时候。
就会变成1500万。
如果继续持有到80岁。
这可以达到一个亿小目标。
贝索斯曾经问巴菲特。
你的投资逻辑这么简单有效。
为什么全世界没有人负质你。
做到和你一样富有。
巴菲特回答
因为没有人愿意慢慢辩付。
反过来说
如果你愿意慢慢辩付。
那么人人都有可能变得富有。
当然长期能够获取10%年化收益。
并不容易
他意味着每青年资产翻倍。
在正常的年龄里
多数人会满足与这个收益。
然而当盛宴来临
当身边充斥着翻倍收益。
乃至10倍百倍报复故事的时候。
欲望没借的作用开始发酵。
10%的收益便再也不相了。
换句话说
10%的收益接近于你的内在欲望。
而翻倍收益10倍收益。
是你的模仿欲望
模仿欲望太强大了。
它会驱使许多人加入追逐的游戏。
追逐风口 追逐热门赛道。
甚至用棒杆增加赌注。
如果追得早的话
那么你自然能在这盛宴里分得一倍耕。
很值得庆贺
但如果追在盛宴即将散产的时刻。
那就需要当心泡沫破裂的痛苦反噬了。
重来投资创始人
邱国根先生说过一句话。
投资这一行即可实实在来。
错过机会固然令人遗憾。
但是也不必过度傲恼。
真正糟糕的是因此背叛自己的投资和人生纪律。
股市机会常在
如果AI真的是一场切实的生产力革命。
那么它一定能够改造千行百业。
机会将层出不穷
理性的做法
不是把自己C进已经拥挤不堪的地方。
而是去寻找未被充分发掘的。
上且被低估的下一个广。
道德经第九章说
吃而盈之不如其以。
吃而瑞之不可残饱。
财物积累到都快满意出来了。
不如懂得收手
弃无魔力的越是丰利。
越是难以长久
第46章说
祸莫大于不知足
就莫大于欲得
故知足知足常足矣。
他的意思是说
世界上没有比不知足更大的灾祸。
没有比贪婪更大的过错。
所以由知足而生出的满足。
才是永恒的富足
老子的经与良言也符合复利之道。
八毛医生物质欲望很低。
他们推崇延迟享受。
却最终享有俱复
投资界有句老话
一年五倍者如过江之挤鱼。
五年翻页倍者却了落成心。
追求短期爆发还是长期复利。
这里边藏着巨大的价值观和欲望的分页。
所以财富之道也是一门如何看待。
和管理欲望的学问。
你有什么样的欲望。
决定你有什么样的投资行为。
投资是一场马拉松。
而不是百米赛跑
在人生顶费中
我们需要时刻问问自己。
哪些欲望是我们
应当坚守的内在欲望。
哪些是外部的欲望没见。
赋予我们的模仿欲望。
这样或许有助于
帮助我们摆脱牛市交造症。
也有助于我们在财富。
与人生的道路上
走得更稳 更远
以上就是本期播放的全部内容。
希望对大家有所启发。
我们下一期再见